good to have you here as a guest on the
Richardson show Chris thanks for calling
in happy to be rich you bet so let's
talk about this situation what what what
was determined what was in the findings
of facts that you can bring to light
here well what this boiled down to and
and the Sixers have been aware of this
information now for a few days the the
burner accounts that are in question
before them they were established and
operated by Bryan Colangelo wife this
has been suspected for over a week now
and really since this broke it it's
immediately you start to think about
family members and his wife immediately
became a prime target of this
investigation so they traced it back
they confronted her with it she actually
admitted to all of it
the question over the last 24 to 48
hours I've been told the Sixers were
wrestling with and even the law firm was
was how involved in what knowledge -
Bryan Colangelo have and even if he
didn't have any knowledge could the
Sixers for lack of a better word you
know divorce him from the actions made
by his wife and ultimately they
concluded that they could not these that
these tweets formation it that was both
a little reckless and certainly
sensitive when it came to some medical
information it was it was simply not do
you simply couldn't separate Colangelo
from the things his wife did Wow Chris
there's no other way to put it just Wow
it is it is Rick post bunker story that
I've ever in my time covering the NBA
bonker story cutting in and out right
there so what you said just be most
bunker story I've ever covered so I
guess when it all comes down to it the
Sixers sitting down Colangelo and
figuring this stuff out they could not
determine what what what role he had in
this the
the law firm couldn't do that at all
they don't make good they couldn't
determine if he had knowledge of these
accounts existence prior to this report
coming out they they understood that
that he was aware of it of course after
the fact but he strenuously denied any
knowledge of it beforehand now there's
there's not a lot of people in the NBA
that really believe that rich you know
for accounts like this being in
existence the number of tweets that were
put out there you're hard-pressed to
find too many people that believe he was
completely ignorant to to all of it but
they couldn't find any proof and and
that was their their their findings
their they did find enough evidence to
suggest that Colangelo as they put it
was careless and in some cases reckless
with pretty sensitive information and
that's the reference some of the medical
stuff that was out there about real
Okafor and certainly mark helpful is it
true that according to the findings of
facts that Colangelo zwipes phone was
factory reset wiped clean when it was
handed in that I don't know that that
there's a lot of stuff out there right
now that that's speculative but I don't
know where we know about that stuff all
right then let's turn the page here
Chris because this is it you know it
it's when you say bonkers it's also
deeply personal right I mean it that you
can't get more personal than this sort
of thing but it did it did mess with the
business of the Philadelphia 76ers at
the end of the day David Griffin clearly
is is a general manager with experience
with a ring with a ring for LeBron who
is going to be a free agent again on
July 1st is that the no brainer choice
here I think it is and I'm writing a
column about that this topic right now I
mean they the Sixers in a press
conference they said that you know this
process could take you know a month they
could bleed into July that that's insane
to me I mean there are some good
candidates out there internally there's
someone named Mark Eversley who's a very
respected guy they could talk to him
certainly there are other executives out
there to talk to you but David Griffin
is a home run choice I mean putting
aside the the LeBron
part of it rich and that I don't think
that would be a big factor of any in
hiring him this guy built the
championship team and you can say well
he built a team with LeBron around it
it's not easy to have limited assets and
fine guys like Kyle Korver and jr. Smith
and Iman Shumpert it and make all those
pieces work David Griffin is a
high-level GM and not as importantly but
somewhat important he's also a really
engaging guy media-friendly does media
now and is in the last couple of years
since leaving last year since leaving
Cleveland you kind of need someone in
place to do damage control in addition
to being a terrific executive he's a guy
that would you know put out a lot of
fires that are around this Philadelphia
organization right now so if they're not
calling him every hour every day they're
making a mistake Chris Mannix a few more
minutes left with Chris Mannix of Yahoo
Sports here on the Rich Eisen show we
had Brian Wynn Horst on in our number
one we had BJ Armstrong in studio on
Monday BJ said that free agency won't
begin until LeBron makes his decision
Brian said LeBron has no earthly idea
right now as we're sitting here what he
thinks is gonna happen on July 1 what is
your reading of the tea leaves here
Chris well III agree with with BJ that
you know the subjective moves won't be
made into laughter LeBron decides
because there are teams that will be
either clearing cap space or have cap
space that are going to be saving that
for a LeBron decision so I grew that III
Brian's covered LeBron longer than I
have but I based on LeBrons history and
and and what you hear you know just in
whispers you're hard-pressed to believe
that he doesn't have some idea of what
he wants to do he is sitting back saying
I'm going to Houston unless they screw
it up I'm going to Philadelphia if they
get the right to him but I think he's
got some ideas in mind maybe sir I think
has a pretty strong idea of how he feels
about Cleveland and in that situation so
I think he's he's you know he and his
team are certainly in the developmental
stages of deciding where he wants to go
but I think there's been some thought
put into it already who's going to shoot
their shot with him
Chris who do you think is gonna say you
know you here's my Yolo presentation - I
I feel like I feel like Houston rich you
know for starters if the Chris Paul
connection is really strong I mean we
know that the front where the friendship
dates back to the family relationship
and I think the recruitment by Chris
Paul and James Harden over the next few
weeks is going to be extremely hard and
extremely tough for LeBron to just kind
of turn away from moreover you have a GM
and daryl morey who's actually a
creating cap space and in doing that all
the things you need to do to define the
room to bring LeBron in they make sense
because one thing we know about LeBron
is that wherever he goes it's gonna put
him in a better position to win a
championship than the one he's in right
now and Houston on paper and in real
life they are the one team that that you
add LeBron James to it and you look like
them as a real contender against gold so
then the last one for you Chris before I
send you back to writing your column on
on David Griffin in the GM search for
Philadelphia for Yahoo let's front-load
the conversation that's gonna happen the
minute that we expect the Warriors to
sweep if not win in five games in
advance of the free agency where LeBron
my team up to create another super team
after winning his championships for a
super team surrounded abound that one
time in Cleveland is this good for the
NBA let's talk about how I'm ringing no
it's terrible for the NBA you know
having a top-heavy League is something
the NBA hates and you know Adam silver
last week he kind of tapped danced
around the issue but believe me in the
league office they cringe at these
consistent these rematches for the last
four years at starting every season
knowing who is going to be the champion
at the end of it it's terrible to have
this many super teams I mean look the
only thing the league can do is you know
take the fact that it could be three or
four super teams next year and so it's
still top heavy league but it might not
just be one if you add LeBron to the
Rockets all of a sudden the Western
Conference is really interesting I
personally think that Boston is going to
go into next season as the favorite or
Co favorite to win the entire thing and
you don't know what's going to happen
Philadelphia if they wind up luring a
Paul George or somebody else into that
mix oh the fact that it top-heavy is
terrible for the NBA but if top with 14
instead of one it's sort of a small
consolation Chris thanks for the call
we'll be calling you back prior to the
draft and obviously during free agency
don't tell Dad I'm not allowed to cheat
on him it's okay Chris there's there's
enough Chris Mannix to go around there
really well you know rich he's he's
making me shave my head this summer as
part of a lost bet I should consult with
you on on you know sort of dynamics on
aerodynamics and like attachments like
how deep should I go things like that I
mean I might need a little help I'm
there for you Chris on there you go
that's Chris Mannix the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience